I want to get to some breaking news we
are monitoring a magnitude 7.3
earthquake struck Japan off the coast of
Fukushima home to the nuclear power
plant badly damaged in March 2011 after
the biggest quake ever recorded in
Japanese history and that ensuing
tsunami we all remember this time a
tsunami alert has been triggered again
for more I want to bring in Bloomberg's
Tokyo bureau chief on the phone cause
Inori Takata joining us now from Tokyo
so what exactly is the latest on the
damage so far we're looking right now
cause Inori at live pictures from the
state-run broadcaster NHK we've seen
reports of waves a meter high already
though they're predicting waves of up to
3 meters what can you tell us yes so we
have had the initial wave of the tsunami
hit the coast of Fukushima and the
northern prefecture x' the the damage
from the quake and the tsunami so far
have been very limited at this point
what we're looking into is the the
damage or the rather the the cooling
system at the Fukushima plant that is
used to cool the the radioactive element
has stopped they're saying that this
will not immediately lead to any issues
but this is I think something that we
need to keep monitoring so obviously
this is the same nuclear reactor that
was hit now five years ago talk to us a
little bit about how the plant and the
area has recovered and you know what
could be yet another blow so the the
immediate residents around in the
vicinity of the plant have been
evacuated and many of them have not been
able to return yet the workers are in
this christimas plant on they had the
the the the reconstruction or rather the
attempt the the workers are there to to
contain the situation and the situation
has so far been stabilizing since the
since the 2011 earthquakes so at this
point is it said I think the damage on
the nuclear plant itself as far as we
can tell there hasn't been anything
significant the only thing that is
worrying at this point is the fact that
the cooling system has stopped um and as
I said this would not be in
caused an immediate impact but it is
something that will need monitoring
Prime Minister Ave has just spoken from
Argentina tell us a little bit more
about what he had to say he basically
said that Japan is we the world lessons
learned from the 2011 quake and tsunami
and that the government has linked to
action is ready to take the size of
action as needed and and then the local
broadcaster in the NHK broadcaster has
been has been warning citizens all in
throughout the morning who evacuate and
take take head to higher ground all
right cause Inori Takata our Bloomberg
News Tokyo bureau chief thank you so
much for that update we'll continue to
monitor the situation in Fukushima and
bring you any headlines as we have them